So Firebase provides us with
a bunch of features for
free so, is it doing anything
automatically to protect our data?
>> Not anything automatically
that I know of.
But why don't you check it out.
>> Yeah, check it out.
Okay, well about the security and
rules tab of the dashboard.
Well, this seems pretty unsecured.
It's a little bit troubling.
Why do you say that?
What about all that permissioning and
log in flow stuff you talked about
when designing version point three.
>> That was client side security.
So, here we have the Firebase server and
the client side app.
Anyone using the shopping list plus
plus Android app will get any of
the security and permissioning
that I built into the app itself.
Things like needing to be logged in
before seeing any data in the app, or
needing to be the owner of the shopping
list before seeing the share icon to
share your shopping list with friends.
But again, this is all client side
logic the server knows nothing about.
By default,
the server itself is wide open,
allowing our data to be
written by anyone or anything.
Now if all communication is done via
the Android app things are okay.
But say in hopefully the near future
we make a iOS app and a web app for
Shopping List plus plus.
And as a team what we probably do is try
to implement the same security features
in the Android app in
both of these other apps.
Now I'm not iOS programmer or
a web app programmer.
So I just kind of have to hope that
who's ever making these two apps
knows what they're doing.
Let's say that the iOS girl
knows what she's doing.
But whoever made the web
app was a little sloppy and
introduced some security bugs.
So even though these clients
were implemented correctly.
One client being implemented incorrectly
jeopardizes the entire database.
This is where you might be wishing that
there was just one place where you could
enforce what can and
can't be done with the data.
Because otherwise again we're relying
on every single client to implement
security perfectly and in the same way.
>> Right and
that's the purpose of server side rules.
Namely those Firebased security
rules I've been hounding you about.
>> All right, all right JP you're right.
We should do something about security.
Come to think of it.
Jeez.
>> What?
>> Well I just realized there's an even
bigger security flaw than just writing
a web app with a bug in it.
Remember when we first wrote our Android
app I didn't have to do anything to
verify that the app was owned by
the same person that owned the Firebase.
So going back to my data
here is a JS fiddle and
it's just some arbitrary
JavaScript here.
And basically I just copied this
from the quick start guide for
writing JavaScript for Firebase, and
if I run this it actually
affects my Firebase over here.
And this could have been run by anybody,
I mean,
there is nothing that required me to
verify where this code was coming from.
So it looks like, basically anywhere.
Anyone in the world can write,
read data to our database.
Okay JP, it looks like we kind
of are open to security threats.
So why don't you tell me what we can
do with Firebase security rules?
>> You got it.